what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so getting into Dark Knight's metal
number one this is proving itself to be
a really cool story is a very elaborate
story but Scott Snyder stories are
always that way I mean the oh it took
him the better part of like four story
arts to build up to the reveal of the
Joker so it was it's pretty interesting
in terms of how he does his stories but
the whole idea is that this opens up
with basically this sort of story that's
given to us from Carter Hall remember
Carter Hall is basically Hawkman and
Hawk man is this guy that has this
origin story where he's effectively
destined to die and be reborn time and
time again the same thing goes for
Kendra Saunders they're effectively
lovers that they'll always die and
they'll always be reborn they won't know
who the other is and their story is to
basically find and encounter one another
to essentially be at the other side
until they die and the process repeats
itself but the idea of dark nights metal
is to introduce this concept of in metal
and what it does or at least what it did
for Carter Hall and for Kendra Saunders
is it basically said that somewhere
along the line in the origin of their
lives back before they started this
process of death and rebirth they
encountered in metal from just some you
know alien civilization somewhere and
the idea was that when they were stabbed
by a blade that was made of entha metal
it set them on the process of dying and
being reborn presumably for all eternity
the whole idea of the diary of Carter
Hall so to speak with regards to dark
nights metal is that he was on a quest
to find out what M fettle was and why it
caused him to live this process of death
and rebirth over and over and over again
but because of the fact that he dates
back to the earliest days of
civilization he's seen a multitude of
things take place and so this story
basically opens up with references to
three different tribes the first is the
tribe of the wolf the second is a tribe
of the bear and the third is the tribe
of the bird now the first two are pretty
straightforward the third is a little
bit kind of weird and it really requires
a little bit of speculation on our part
the tribe of the wolf is basically the
tribe of Vandal Savage the tribe of the
bear is the tribe of the immortal man
and the tribe of the bird might be like
the court of owls but it's most likely
Hawkman himself now with the tribe of
the wolf with regards to Vandal Savage
he is a guy who is basically immortal
now the way to originally happen in DC's
storytelling is that the immortal man in
Vandal Savage both basically gained
their immortality from a meteorite
more or less this meteorite crash-landed
on earth Vandal Savage discovered it in
the earliest days of you know caveman
history
it basically imbued him with legitimate
immortality so he could never really die
the immortal man made him amulet out of
the meteorite and his exposure to the
amulet over time is what gave him his
immortality now in the new 52 when BC
basically started retelling the stories
of Batman when we got into things like
the court of owls and the night of owls
and Batman in Game and death of the
family all those stories written by
Scott Snyder the origin of Vandal Savage
was completely reworked and what Scott
Snyder established is that there's
actually this substance on Earth called
Dionysian and dionisije m in its most
pure form was first encountered by
Vandal Savage and that's how he became
immortal it was later encountered by the
Joker but the Joker too encountered an
impure form and the result was that he
constantly had to go back and expose
himself to Dionysian in order to
maintain his longevity it was really
Scott Snyder teasing this idea that so
long as Dionysian was present and
accessible by the Joker he would
effectively be immortal now in the new
we have no references to the immortal
man this is the first time we get it
there's been nothing to indicate the
immortal man exists this seems to be the
first time they were actually having his
character rolled in and of course the
trial of the bird really looking at the
idea of Hawkman this basically indicates
that because he was stabbed with in
metal in the early days of his existence
his tribe he really just kind of had a
group of his own and different things
like that and somehow or another he just
came to be represented with regards to
these different tribes but again it's a
very short little story here because
what this does is it says that these
three tribes are now being greeted with
a fourth tribe the tribe of effectively
the Dark Knights of Barbados now with
regards to the modern day what this does
is it picks up with Mongol now this is
kind of cool because this actually comes
out of what I believe is a three-part
story maybe it's a two-part story in
superman/batman issues five and six from
the new 52 and this dealt with the idea
of a character by the name of Toyman
some kid named Hiro who is basically
like this super smart engineer of sorts
based out of Japan and he had actually
designed a video game system that
eventually turned into a real-life
system in the sense that it was designed
to allow people to jump into this sort
of virtual reality world and engage in
combat but it eventually manifested to
the point that they were controlling
actual people specifically Batman and
Superman so it was an interesting little
bit of storytelling
who has really DC just kind of
experimenting with what people would be
interested in with regards to the launch
of the new 52 but it also drew the
attention of mongol and so this is why
mongol has kidnapped hero because the
two of them were basically familiar with
each other in the sense that hero is the
new 52 iteration of Toyman under control
of mongol he's basically kidnapped the
justice league thrown him on this new
war moon which is basically mongols war
world
and it results in the justice league
being held prisoner using a multitude of
different design devices and
contraptions for example crystallized
red kryptonite which keeps Superman's
powers from manifesting boots that
basically increase gravity to keep the
flash from just running super fast
different things like that and it's just
really just a way to kind of keep them
in place now of course this goes by
pretty fast there's a new device has
been created by Toyman the Justice
leaguer forced to fight it ultimately
Batman realizes that there's basically
these little symbols inside of the
machine itself that hero left there's
the so Batman and the Justice League
would figure out how to actually turn
this machine into a giant Voltron more
or less is what everybody's calling it a
giant mecha of sorts which they can all
pilot it's a Zord
it's the Megazord they're all just kind
of piloting it and of course they use it
to basically overpower Mongol and make
their escape and that's really about it
I mean there's not much going on here
why it was added in I honestly have no
earthly clue but I guess it really is
kind of answered in the fact that when
they return home there's this giant
mountain that's been erected in the
middle of Gotham City which of course
has sent people fleeing for their lives
now of course once the Justice League
actually gets up to it they get inside
the the mountain they start
investigating around what we end up
getting is this sort of residence energy
that runs directly in line with the
energy that Hal Jordan felt from dark
days The Forge and the casting and what
I mean by that is if you guys remember
in those two stories what you'll find
down in the dark nights metal playlist
there was basically this machine of
sorts that Batman had constructed which
ultimately had just been torn to pieces
by the Joker and the idea was that
Batman alongside of the signal do Thomas
the newest addition to the bat family
had uses powers to essentially sort of
rebuild this thing in addition to Green
Lantern using his reign to recreate the
machine so to speak and it resulted in
them working on it but the harmonic
frequency then this machine put off as
it was designed by Batman is exactly
what they're feeling here but it's
basically encasing some sort of pod of
sorts and so in the middle of all this
before they can actually
in open they're basically met with the
arrival of Kendra Saunders now again
this is a bit of an interesting scenario
because it basically treats Kendra
Saunders as if nobody knows who she is
and she's never existed in the new 52
which is kind of interesting here
because it's like this wholly new
introduction of a concept within DC I
mean it's not but DC kind of treats it
that way with regards to this story but
what it does is it begins hitting at the
nature of what's going on with Carter
Hall and again that's why all this
basically comes together in the sense
that in metal came from a place that
nobody really understands and nobody
knows anything about it now we know just
by virtue of the tie-ins that if metal
comes from the dark multiverse but no
one seems to know that instead what
Kendra Saunders does is basically tell
the various superheroes here that when
Carter Hall was going around and
investigating the various issues that
were going on within fettle the idea of
incremental itself were initially the
investigation in his earliest days was
just him as time progressed and people
like Vandal Savage began to rise in
prominence people like the immortal man
began to rise in prominence you know
heroes like Red Tornado who was really a
really cool character from before new 52
as these various heroes began to rise in
prominence Carter Hall basically began
recruiting them to his cause and it was
essentially anybody who could help in
any form or fashion whether they were
scientists engineers whatever the case
may be as long as they were intelligent
they were basically put to task trying
to figure out what in metal is now what
Hendra also does is say that just by
virtue of his own investigations Carter
Hall became aware of the multiverse now
we don't know how she essentially says
this is the multiverse as it exists and
it's essentially the multiversal map
from Final Crisis going into the new 52
the Final Crisis aspect I'd like you to
also keep in the back of your head for a
second but the whole idea is that when
the question was asked word info metal
came from the vibrational frequency that
it emits does not come from any one
particular universe now we've talked
about this with regards to our tie-ins
for Dark Knights metals so if you've
heard those bear with me for a second
but in DC Comics when it comes to
different universes every universe has a
unique energy signature so think of the
energy energy signature like colors
every universe is its own distinct color
if you can become that color you can
enter that universe by saying that
simply if you can vibrate at the correct
frequency you can enter that alternate
universe
that's how the flash was able to jump
from reality to reality in the early
days of DC's creation on the multiverse
back in 1961 it was the idea that the
flash inadvertently vibrated at the
right frequency to enter an alternate
reality now once it was that he realized
what he had done that it basically
became this scenario where DC simply
said the flash can go into any universe
he wants to as long as he vibrates at
the right frequency he has to know what
the frequency is but once he learns he
can vibrate that way and travel from one
universe to another the issue here is
that with each one of these universes
having its own unique frequency the
frequency the in metal puts off is not
attuned to any one of those universes
and so the question that Kendra Saunders
asks and the question that Carter Hall
had asked is if it doesn't come from
this multiverse then where does it come
from
and this is one of the interesting
scenarios that DC's toying around with
that there is the multiverse as it
exists in the main DC line of stories
then there's the dark multiverse and so
the overall idea here is that they are
effectively saying that this dark
multiverse is composed of dark matter
and dark energy and it's actually kind
of interesting because the whole
principle behind this is basically
saying that in the main DC universe
everything is made up of like atoms two
hydrogen atoms and one oxygen atom give
you h2o they give you water but in terms
of the atomic level it's largely empty
space that empty space is composed of
dark matter and dark energy and so what
they're effectively saying is that this
dark multiverse as it exists is far
larger than the main DC Multiverse
itself but they don't know how big the
other thing to keep in mind here is that
this is all speculation there's no
absolute answers here it's literally
Kendra Saunders and everybody trying to
figure out what's going on trying to
understand what's happening at the same
time as they began going through and
actually began researching what was what
she could find from Carter Hall anyway
before he had disappeared into
presumably the Dark multiverse is that
along the line the character of Barbados
this godly being from the dark
multiverse had looked to cross over into
the main DC universe by way of Batman
and that's the whole basis behind this
now of course in the middle of this
whole investigation things really just
kind of pick up when Red Tornado
suddenly wakes up that was a little bit
of a sidetrack here because we'll jump
back into that Batman thing
a second but the whole idea behind this
is that Red Tornado is effectively this
Android that can manipulate winds of
sorts different things like that
DC tried to experiment and turn him into
an turn him into an elemental of sorts
but he was basically a member of the
Justice League for quite some time
Justice League International played some
pretty cool roles here and there but
he's one of those characters that a lot
of older fans were excited to see he's
really neat but his basically DC rolling
his character back into the modern-day
continuity now how he got here we don't
know we simply know that Kendra Saunders
and the Blackhawks have been holding him
captive this entire time but one of the
things that I want you guys to notice is
that with him basically dominating like
Wonder Woman Green Lantern Superman he's
certainly a force to be reckoned with in
terms of what he's capable of but what
he keeps shouting is that they opened
the door and that he warned them not to
open the door now this is a direct
reference to the events of dark nights
the forge and the casting when Batman
activated the device did open the door
to the dark multiverse not realizing
that he did it and that brings us back
to the continuation of this circumstance
because one of the people that Carter
Hall had sent in to investigate the Dark
multiverse was Red Tornado Red Tornado
of course basically returned well the
idea is that Red Tornado is aware of the
fact that if the door is opened to the
dark multiverse all it's going to do is
let in absolute evil so again not a lot
of straight answers coming from Scott
Snyder and that's standard when it comes
to a story telling he gives us a lot of
mysterious a lot of clues you know a lot
of these boy you know what do you think
will happen next for the first you know
two or three issues and then he actually
gets into the meat and potatoes of it
later on now of course in all the panic
Batman basically bails out and makes his
escape because the only reason he was
even there in the first place was to see
how much Kendra Saunders and the Black
Hawks knew now a lot of that goes into
the all-star Batman rebirth line of
stories and the sense that Batman was
aware of Kendra Saunders who is aware of
the Black Hawks the whole point was to
get there see what they know about this
mysterious in metal this material that
he's been researching all this time and
once he found out they had a sample of
it his goal was to get in there take it
and leave and this gets us into the
whole idea of Batman and the events of
Final Crisis and that's one of the
reasons why we covered the Final Crisis
story in the first place is because what
Kendra Saunders basically says is that
going through the verrat the various
wordings of you know Carter Hall himself
ultimately the person that is
responsible for allowing the dark
multiverse into the main DC Universe
Batman himself going by the you know
traditional idea of the word Wayne as
it's been translated over the years now
what the Journal of Carter Hall
basically says here is that initially
Barbados didn't know anything about the
positive multiverse it wasn't until the
events of Final Crisis when Batman was
hit with the Omegas sanctioned by
Darkseid and sent all the way back into
the distant past of humanity's history
that Barbados became aware of the
positive multiverse when Batman was hit
with the Omega sanction and sent into
the past
it sent shockwaves throughout both the
Dark multiverse and the positive
multiverse and with that shockwave
crossing the Dark multiverse Barbados
basically woke up he had this you know
light bulb in his head and realized the
positive multiverse exists and so the
goal was to pass through earth zero the
main DC universe and then go directly
into the positive multiverse and so
that's how it is the final crisis ties
into this story and that's the
significance of Batman when Scott Snyder
in these guys say Batman is the means by
which the Dark multiverse will be let in
it's because one he was sent into the
past in Final Crisis shockwaves were
sent throughout both sides of the
positive and negative multiverse and he
basically created the device and he had
the device designed that would open a
portal to the Dark multiverse not really
knowing what it was that he was doing
and so in the middle of all this when he
basically begins to realize that all of
this is true he's basically met with a
being called dream who's part of a group
called the endless now the endless are a
really really really cool concept in the
realm of DC Comics and we've never
talked about him we've never even a
reference to the endless once so I'm
gonna give you guys a crash course in
what the endless are the endless
originally appeared in the second volume
of Neil Gaiman's Sandman series and The
Sandman series largely dealt with the
idea of just a guy who would get these
sort of prophetic dreams but the endless
are somewhat like DC's answer to
Marvel's cosmic entities but not exactly
the idea is that in the Marvel in the
Marvel Universe the cosmic entities are
sort of this representation of concepts
within the realm of Marvel eternity
represents time and infinity represents
space or something along those lines
the endless in DC's comics are not a
representation of different things they
simply are those things so when it comes
to like the
of the endless it is basically their
concept of people dreaming you know when
you lay down you go to sleep and you
dream about whatever you know that one
girl that you really want to get with or
the one guy you really want to get with
we're getting a rob kore ring whatever
is that you dream about endless is that
the amalgamation of your dreams more or
less but the reason why this matters is
because when it comes to the endless
there's something like seven of them I
think I think it's destiny destruction
death dream I want to save delirium
despair and desire I think is what
they're called I'm not super familiar on
the endless so I apologize if I got
those wrong but for the most part we
don't really see them all that often in
DC at least not in the main DC line of
stories but the whole idea is that the
arrival of dream specifically is done
for a purpose it really seems to be in
the eyes of Scott Snyder an explanation
of what the dark multiverse is the
indication here is that the dark
multiverse is not necessarily a place
where everything that can go wrong has
gone wrong it's a place that was created
by virtue of a nightmarish situation is
basically a multiverse that exists of
all the worst things that can happen
because people dreamed them up it's like
where people's nightmares go coalesce
and then presumably took form the
problem with this and the reason why we
really have to wait for definitive
answers from from Scott Snyder is
because in this story it's basically
established that the dark multiverse
predates the main BC multiverse by quite
a while so if it predates the existing
multiverse people couldn't have dreamt
it up because they weren't alive to
dream it again that's why I guess into
kind of a weird boat in a weird
situation because we're just sort of
left to try to figure out what what's
going on but the very presence of one of
the endless here is a huge deal because
it's the equivalent of in Marvel Comics
if some event takes place and eternity
shows up and says hey man we got to talk
about what's happening that's when you
know these are really getting to pop off
things are really beginning to get
serious because we have basically these
immortal immutable constructs showing up
and telling Batman things are about to
get pretty dire with that being said
guys we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comics explain and make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
Rob core if you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]